[Music]
I'm Paul gray chairman of the
Institute's governing board and it's my
pleasure to have this opportunity to
greet you and to welcome you to MIT for
this conference I bring greetings as
well from Chuck vest who as we speak is
testifying on the hill
concerning federally funded research and
development centers and in particular
the Lincoln Laboratory he expects to be
back around lunchtime and we'll have
some things to say to you toward the end
of the day while the timing of this
colloquium is determined by the present
nature of the lively debate about the
nature and purposes of basic research
and by the likelihood of changes in the
role of the federal government in the
support of research there is a
coincidence in the timing which seems to
me to be worthy of a moment's reflection
it was just 50 years ago this spring
that Vannevar Bush presented to
President harry s truman his report a
report commissioned by President
Franklin D Roosevelt entitled science
the endless frontier van Bush was a
central figure as director of the Office
of scientific research and development
in the coordination of the wartime
efforts to bring science and technology
to bear on the national defense he was
thoroughly familiar with the university
scene having served as dean of
engineering here at MIT in the 1930s and
his vice-president at MIT at a time when
I should note there was but one vice
president he also served later as
president of the Carnegie Institution of
Washington and as an aside I might note
that van in the late 50s was chairman of
the MIT governing board and was in those
years over the years of the 50s 60s and
70s and adviser to six MIT presidents
including this one
president roosevelt's charged the bush
was a challenge that quote the office of
scientific research and development of
which you are the director represents a
unique experiment of teamwork and
cooperation and coordinating scientific
research and in applying existing
scientific knowledge to the solutions of
the technical problems paramount in the
war there is no reason why the lessons
found in this experiment cannot be
profitably employed in times of peace
the information the techniques and the
research experience developed by OSRD
and by the thousands of scientists in
the universities and in private industry
should be used in the days of peace
ahead for the improvement of the
national health the creation of new
enterprises bringing new jobs and the
betterment of national standards of
living
now vans report Express two priorities
and I quote first we must have plenty of
men and women trained in science for
upon them depends both the creation of
new knowledge and its application to
practical purposes second we must
strengthen the centres of basic research
which are principally the colleges
universities and research institutes
these institutions provide the
environment which is most conducive to
the creation of new scientific knowledge
at least under pressure for immediate
tangible results van Bush's report had
many of the important details right as
well for example with respect to student
aid he said as follows again I quote the
government should provide a reasonable
number of undergraduate scholarships and
graduate fellowships in order to develop
scientific talent in American youth
there are talented individuals in every
segment of the population but with few
exceptions those without the means of
buying higher education go without it if
ability and not the circumstances of
family fortune is made to determine who
shall receive higher education in
science
then we shall be assured of constantly
improving quality at every level of
scientific activity good words for 1945
good words for 1995 science the endless
frontier provided the basis for ongoing
federal support of scientific research
and for the growth and development of
the research universities it led to the
establishment by the Congress of the NIH
and the NSF to agencies now in the
vanguard of research and student support
and to the encouragement of continued
research support by the Department of
Defense and the Atomic Energy Agency it
promoted the development of policies and
practices which permitted the
reimbursement of institutions of higher
education for the research which they
undertook on behalf of the government
Bush's report set the stage for the
federal patronage of research in
colleges and universities and of
graduate education in science and
engineering patronage which has led to
the flowering of a network of research
universities that are now the envy of
the world 50 years later with the Cold
War ended under the shadow of a large
federal budget deficit all of us
University faculty and administrators
representatives of government and
industrial leaders are seeking a new
modus operandi one which will permit and
indeed encourage the continued flowering
of research and of the education of the
men and women who will influence the
21st century a mode which will in FDR's
phrase enable the lessons found in this
experiment to be used in the days of
peace ahead for the improvement of the
national health the creation of new
enterprises bringing new jobs and the
betterment of national standards of
living of course by experiment the
president meant World War two but now
nearly half a century later the phrase
it seems to me applies equally well to
the Cold War that new mode will surely
and most appropriately lead to some
further evolution of relationships
between universities and industry and
I'm pleased to see American industry
so well represented here today may our
discussions today help generate the
insights the shared commitment necessary
to permit government universities and
Industry to work together to bring about
in these new days these old ends it's
now my pleasure to introduce the key
figure in the organization of this
conference Robert Birgeneau Dean of
science at MIT Bob came to the Institute
nearly 20 years ago via the University
of Toronto Yale Oxford and the Bell
Laboratories his research is primarily
concerned with the phases and phase
transition behavior of novel states of
matter such as one in two dimensional
magnets liquid crystals surface
monolayers
and metal and semiconductor surfaces he
and his collaborators are pioneering in
the use of synchrotron x-ray light for
high resolution studies of condensed
matter
thank you for first of all I'd like
course to welcome all of the speakers to
our symposium today science in the
national interest a shared commitment
we're very fortunate to have a speaker's
distinguished representatives of the
federal government industry and academia
I also want to welcome all of the
attendees in fact many of you have
probably looked over the list and it's
an equally distinguished group we have
here in the audience today
representatives of 58 corporations 48
universities many national laboratories
most of the MIT research and academic
leadership and many governmental
officials our purpose here today as you
know is to discuss science and its role
in our national enterprise and
especially today with emphasis on
industry and the industry University
partnership separate equally important
component in this is of course the
National Laboratories which will be
reviewed in future symposium like this
one our inspiration for the session
today is of course this document which
are all familiar with clinton-gore
documents science in the national
I'd like to quote two sections from it
first section reads as follows the
challenges of the 21st century will
place a high premium on sustained
excellence in scientific research in
education we approach the future with a
strong foundation built by the wise and
successful stewardship of this
enterprise over many decades as we just
heard from Paul beginning with Vannevar
Bush and with an investment strategy
that was framed
during this administration's first month
as three interconnected strategic goals
first long-term economic growth that
creates jobs and protects the
environment second a government that is
more productive and more responsive to
the needs of its citizens
third and manifestly from our parochial
point of view most importantly world
leadership and basic science mathematics
and engineering the clinton-gore
document then proceeds to say therefore
we set the following goals for our
stewardship of Science in the national
interest first maintain leadership
across the frontiers of scientific
knowledge secondly enhance connections
between fundamental research and
national goals third stimulate
partnerships that promote investments in
fundamental science and engineering and
effective use of physical human and
financial resources and we will
undoubtedly today hear a particular
emphasis on this partnership aspect of
our relationships for produced the
finest scientists and engineers for the
21st century of course that's a very
special responsibility of our research
universities fifth raise scientific and
technological literacy of all Americans
equally important goal the document then
proceeds to say while we perceive these
could pursue these goals amiss rapid
change we must not lose sight of the
core values that have enabled our nation
to achieve so much over the last 50
years the United States developed a
unique and highly successful system for
advancing scientific research in
universities medical schools and
independent research centers and in
federal and industrial laboratories our
system rests on a strong commitment to
investigator-initiated research and
merit review based on evaluation by
scientific peers
the system maintains the emphasis on
excellence and brings new people and new
ideas into the research enterprise it's
manifestly an inspiring almost brilliant
statement and of course our purpose here
today is to discuss collectively how
we're going to achieve the goals which
are stated so eloquently here I'd now
like to proceed to introduce mark right
and this will be a flattering
introduction for two reasons first of
all he's my boss and determines my
salary and and secondly I got an email
at about 9:30 this morning from which
had to be email rather than telephone
from George Whitesides who's one of the
afternoon speakers who informs us that
he has extreme limit laryngitis in fact
I don't see George in the audience and
so I had a moment of panic and then I
thought now who's the best
extemporaneous speaker that I know who
can talk on any subject in including the
daunting task of responding to John
Mackay and of course I thought of none
other than Mark Ryden so I picked up on
the phone at 9:30 and said mark can you
can you substitute for George Whitesides
in the limit that his voice really
doesn't work and Mark emerged for about
30 seconds and then he said sure I'll do
it so anyway so we really appreciate
mark for his agreement to step in mark
was an undergraduate student at Florida
State University and a graduate student
at Cal Tech came here to MIT as a
faculty member at an extraordinarily
young age of 22 and by age 28 was
already a full professor he proceeded to
become a head of the department actually
mark was head of chemistry while I was
ahead of physics and then four years ago
mark moved up into the position of
Provost during this meteoric rise in our
system mark has simultaneously had a
truly brilliant research career in which
he's maintained a large and
extraordinarily productive research
effort in chemistry and photo chemistry
in particular and electrochemistry has
been broadly honored for that the
Lawrence award he was I think one of the
very first if not
scientists officially declared a genius
by the MacArthur Foundation a burden
which he perhaps still carries why we
expect so much of him as Provost and
then has gone on
besides these scientific contributions
really to provide outstanding leadership
for us in academic and actually also in
financial matters here at MIT mark thank
you very much Bob that was relatively
generous
2% raise what do you think I'm grateful
that so many of you would plan to spend
the day with us talking about science in
the national interest and as bob has
indicated you'll hear more from me a
little bit later this afternoon my role
now is to coordinate our opening session
which will involve three speakers three
presenters and the procedure will be
that I'm going to invite each of the
presenters to make their remarks and
afterwards we will have an opportunity
to have a debate with them questions and
answers so I'd like you to hold your
questions until the conclusion of all
three presentations the first speaker is
dr. John H Gibbons Jack Gibbons
he is the chief architect of this policy
which bob has referred to as President
Clinton's advisor on science and
technology dr. Gibbons of course has
played a great role in the formulation
of the document that some of you will
have reviewed you may have also had an
opportunity as I have had to quickly
review the President's budget request
which was announced yesterday and I
think you can see some strong elements
there that suggests that there's strong
support toward achieving the goals that
have been set out in this policy
statement dr. Gibbons in his own right
is an internationally recognized
scientist he started his distinguished
career after receiving a PhD in physics
from Duke University he joined Oakridge
like Oak Ridge National Laboratory where
he spent
approximately 15 years working on the
structure of atomic nuclei with emphasis
on the role of Neutron captured dr.
Gibbons ultimately made most
distinguished contributions in his
leadership of the office of Technology
Assessment he spent two six-year terms
in that capacity
prior to b2 becoming appointed as the
presidential science advisor on February
2nd 1993 dr. Gibbons is a fellow of the
American Physical Society and the fellow
of the American Association for the
Advancement of science and has been
elected to the National Academy of
Engineering dr. Gibbons will now tell us
about science in the national interest I
will make only one quote from this
document it says this country must
sustain world leadership in science
mathematics and engineering if we are to
meet the challenges of today and of
tomorrow that summary statement was made
by President Clinton on November 23rd
1993 the nation's chief scientist will
now tell us how we are to achieve that
world leadership dr. Gibbons
thank you mark I was reminded when you
rose that my distinguished colleague
Marci Greenwood who left of deanship
posted at Cal Davis to join us at OSTP
described university management in
somewhat biblical terms she described
the president as a Shepherd of the flock
and the Provost as the crook of his
staff so I'm not sure that's true but I
thought you ought to hear that work and
I do want to start out by saying how
much I and my associates have
appreciated that many contributions that
MIT has played in the work that we've
been trying to do at OSTP a Chuck vest
for example that typically is back in
Washington today I'm not sure whether
you add or dock his salary for this
public service he's given but he was
absolutely instrumental in the
revolution that has undergone has now
well underway at NASA and the redesign
of the space station and its
internationalization a drawing Russia
into that orbit very much stems from
Chuck and I recall one night near the
end of the of a marathon work that the
committee that Chuck chaired the last
night Chuck literally the last closing
moment stayed up 27 hours working
steadily he said it felt like a graduate
student again and Ernie Moniz who's who
I think are you in the room over here in
the corner spent a good deal of time
with us in our office and was
instrumental in helping shape this
document that we're focusing on today
and Ernie we really appreciate the time
you spend with us I'm not sure how the
physics department is a fairing but you
certainly made enormous contributions
and I'm also pleased that we're having
this session here in New England in in
Cambridge today because of all parts of
the country this is is in the very
forefront of its dependence and
commitment to the pushing of the
frontiers of knowledge as a means not
only to lift our spirits but also to
provide for our future and here in a
city that is so deeply committed both to
research and graduate education is a
perfect place to be to try this to begin
this dialogue we are certainly here
gathered to in a sense celebrate 50
years of of extraordinary endurance of
the document that Vannevar Bush
developed in a very different time of
our nation's history but the underlying
message of that report was and remains
that fundamental research is the is
essentially an investment the finest
kind of investment because it both
provides knowledge that is in ultimately
needed to respond to our nation's
technological requirements and
opportunities but also to educate
innovative scientists and engineers that
will drive that engine of economic
growth the technology and supply the
fuel to that growth to that engine which
is science itself so I'm particularly
pleased to be here at this time and it
gives me a great personal happiness to
be here at the site of the University
from whence cometh Jim Killian Jerry
Wiesner and Frank pres as some of my
predecessors in the office of advisor to
the President Bush's insightful and
enduring vision brought us to an
unmatched capability in terms of
research and education and it of course
built on the triumph of Science and
Technology in the in the fighting of
World War two and came at a time in
which we were embarking on a seemingly
interminable era of
or in which the our survival depended on
our cunning our technological ingenuity
in providing the kind of defense that
this nation was going to have to provide
not only for itself but for the free
world but a host of sea changes
occurring at an ever-increasing rate
today requires to view science policy
from a different vantage point than Bush
did in those years thanks to his work
and those that followed we no longer
have to create a science and technology
infrastructure but rather we have the
necessity to preserve to enhance and to
extend this extraordinary strength that
we now possess that has been created
over this past half-century the driver
for much of this build-up has been
fearful concern for our national
security and happily much of that
concern now has been at least dissipated
but we are now faced with a much more
complex task of marshalling the Science
and Technology Enterprise to contribute
even more effectively to improving the
quality of life for all Americans and
laying in place a knowledge heritage for
our descendants we now face surging
international economic competition as
other nations are able to harness
Science and Technology and
communications and also their highly
educated workforces we face new social
challenges such as changing us
demographics that stem from income
employment and immigration patterns and
we face educational challenges both in
the re-examination of our education of
scientists engineers but also in
advancing a broader science and math
literacy to the level that will be
required for literacy and citizenship
and economic capabilities in the 21st
century now these changes and other
issues such as the compelling need to
control the
budget have led us over the past two
years to revisit that vision for a
national investment in science and
technology and to reassess our plans for
encouraging a high rate of return on the
investment so today I'd like to spend a
few minutes talking about three things
one the investment strategy of the
clinton-gore administration for science
and technology the progress we've been
making we believe in achieving or at
least pursuing those goals
and what we might expect as we proceed
the administration starting point was a
commitment to many of the same general
precepts that have been held by
successive administrations both
Democratic and Republican over I would
say a half a century at least our broad
investment strategy was put forward in
the administration's first months as
three coupled goals first a long-term
economic growth that both creates jobs
and protects and invite the environment
a challenge to the old notion that
somehow environment and economic growth
worry an antagonistic or at least in
orthogonal II related we offered the
substitute paradigm that if you're smart
about the way you do things you can
create both economic growth and
environmental protection at the same
time secondly a government that is more
productive and more responsive to the
needs of its citizens in a sense
reinventing itself much as American
industry has done over the past decade
or two and third world leadership in
science math and engineering as a
fundamental underpinning to these ideas
and the administration elaborate
elaborated its perspectives on the role
of Technology in achieving the first of
these goals in the release called
technology for America's economic growth
that we released in San Jose in February
1993 we believe that the government is a
vital partner in promoting technologies
that are critical to economic growth the
creation of good jobs and the meeting of
common
of our nation such as environmental
education but needs that cannot attract
adequate private investment because of
the inability to capture sufficient
returns in our partnerships with
business for pre-commercial technology
development our cardinal rule is to use
government resources only where they are
essential and where the payoff to
society as a whole is likely to be quite
large furthermore we make sure that the
private sector puts up half or more of
the resources for these partnerships a
quasi market test indeed in order to
make sure that the technological risk is
worth taking we undoubtedly will be
discussing the structure and the
purposes and the successes of these
programs at NIST and that the LED at
NIST and at the Department of Defense
with the new Congress in the coming
months and I'm pleased that Anita Jones
is with us today as we will get into
these matters
the second goal of the administration
was described in the national
performance review which came out first
in the fall of 1993
Vice President Gore I think as you know
is actively leading that effort to
reinvent government from top to bottom
for now and for the future eliminating
programs that no longer serve our
national purpose replacing them with
invigorated activities that are
responsive to both present and future
needs and the aspirations of our
citizens effective utilization of
technology is a key and in a common
thread that runs through these efforts
to reinvent ourselves the third goal
focuses on the foundation of
technological development that is basic
science math and engineering and a year
ago we started that reassessment of
science policies by convening a forum at
the academy title science in the
national interest and following several
months of discussion after that forum
and many excellent statements made by
participants including the vice
president the president
we got together and worked hard and
received a lot of input from from the
private sector both academic academic
and academia and industry and created
the document which you have before you
today and five basic goals for our
stewardship of science in the national
interest were put forward maintaining
leadership across the frontiers of
scientific knowledge enhancing
connections between fundamental research
and national goals stimulate
partnerships that promote investments in
fundamental science and engineering and
effective use of physical human and
financial resources producing the finest
scientists and engineers for the 21st
century
and finally raising the scientific
literacy of all Americans these are
highly interconnected goals as as you
know they start with our uncompromising
need to work across scientific
disciplines and frontiers it is seldom
possible to anticipate which areas of
fundamental science are going to bring
forth surprising and important
breakthroughs and therefore we can't
afford to limit our future by narrowing
our our range of inquiry
you know I recall from graduate school
and I was working in a nuclear structure
there were still a few students hanging
on with James Frank and others on
optical spectroscopy and I thought of
them as kind of people that were lost in
the sands of time and lo and behold look
how tables flipped when we get to modern
day science so you just have to be
awfully careful when you try to think
that you know which is the most
important frontier of knowledge to be
working in we've also recognized
explicitly the deep connection between
frontier research and education and the
need for raising the standards of public
literacy and science and technology for
our citizens to remain competitive and
prosperous in the new global economy and
I'll return to that in a little bit
in a departure from the bush cannon of a
what has been called a linear model of
science in which it flows from
unidirectionally from fundamental
science toward technological application
the clinton-gore administration's
science and technology initiatives are
based on a on a recognition that science
and technology are intertwined in a
multitude of ways each building
constantly on the gains in the others
domain it is certainly true that
technological advance ultimately depends
on fundamental science and on the highly
trained people that are educated at our
colleges and universities but advances
in fundamental science are often made
possible by technological advances and
old distinctions between basic and
applied science really if they ever made
sense no longer makes sense in today's
labs for instance newly derived
fundamental understanding of molecular
biology you'll notice how I brought
along the restriction enzyme clipped DNA
today quickly yields ideas for new
products and manufacturing processes
which in turn not only raise questions
for further fundamental research but
also give rise to new technologies that
further enable research at the frontier
supercomputers which is obviously an
american-led technology that was
ultimately made possible by basic
research in quantum mechanics and
solid-state physics and other
fundamental areas have opened up new
fields of Commerce and science including
new insights into solid-state physics so
progress in such fundamental fields as
astronomy or subatomic physics
depend an often DRI of technological
breakthroughs in optics computing or
superconductors and sometimes applied
research itself provides a fundamental
breakthrough as with Arnold Penzias and
Wilson x' discovery of the Cosmic
Microwave Background that they found
when they were working on improving
radio community antenna x' and radio
communications
the fundamental point is that basic
science applied science technology
though different in approach and
motivation and scale are profoundly
interdependent we therefore need a
Science and Technology Policy that
factors in and captures these enhanced
connections sustained support for
fundamental science is not at odds with
our programs for stimulating
pre-competitive technology development
on the contrary a vibrant Applied
Research and Development Enterprise
enriches the conduct of fundamental
science this interdependence calls for
new kinds of partnerships so that the
fruits of our R&D investments can better
serve our nation Science in the national
interest also emphasized the strong
links between basic research and
education progress toward our goals must
importantly most importantly depends on
our human resource base our country
needs the best scientists and engineers
nature yields her secrets to those who
are best prepared and persistent in
their work we must draw upon our full
human resource meaning that we have
great potential through increased
participation of women and
underrepresented minorities in the
scientific enterprise we also need to
raise substantially over all scientific
and technical literacy so that all of
our citizens can not only maintain the
quality of their life and participate in
the great national adventure but also
share in new employment opportunities
that arise from advancing science and
technology and sustained the national
interest in science because they after
all are the benefactors the the
purchasers of these kinds of activities
our companies our universities our
government all rely on a well-trained
and versatile workforce well these are
some of the challenges that are laid out
in the little blue document they are
formidable and will require both the
resources of the government and active
participation of industry and academia
all of us share responsibilities here
and that's why I'm so pleased to see in
this and further planned meetings across
the country so many of our Science and
Technology leaders from academia
industry government engaged in this
further assessment but clearly we're
living in times of severe fiscal
constraints on our federal budget trying
to bring a deficit down and attempting
to it ensure at the same time that all
Americans are brought along with our
improving economy nevertheless prudent
planning requires that our investment
strategies be sustained for the
long-term health of our economy our
defense our environment and our personal
health thus we've made a policy
commitment in the report as I quote our
investment budget in fundamental science
will be improved in the short term as we
examine existing resources and to match
the growing importance of science as a
foundation of modern society increased
with future improvements in the federal
government's fiscal condition the and of
course I haven't seen a lot of
improvements in our fiscal condition
except that we're getting this deficit
down which is a sin akwonton for a
moving toward the future the essential
truths which underlie this commitment
that I just quoted are widely endorsed
by leading economist Laura Tyson who
chairs the Council of Economic Advisers
has noticed and I quote that the
fastest-growing economies around the
world are those that remain at the
forefront of scientific discovery and
technological innovation it is clear
that advances in knowledge coming from
basic science and science based
technology and moving through to product
and process applications are a major
determinant of our living standards they
in quotes they're on the basis of many
studies the return to science base
investments is quite high the average
rate of return on investment in the US
economy is if my numbers are right
around 8 8 14%
the average private rate of return on
research and development investments
runs 20 to 30 percent the average social
rate of return on investments in R&D is
about 50 percent although this number
varies quite widely and it ranges from
over a hundred percent to less to
perhaps 25 percent it depends on the
industry in the circumstance but with
rare exception the social rate of return
on fundamental science is exceptionally
high and can only be evaluated however
retrospectively sometimes it takes
decades after the work has been carried
out for its importance to be recognized
one of the recent Nobel prizes was based
on work that was actually carried out
over 20 years ago
therefore the administration's strategy
is to give the highest priority in
federal support to areas for which the
private sector is likely to
significantly under invest in terms of a
national optimum that is the social rate
of return being substantially higher
than the rate of return that can be
captured by the individual firm industry
though has a major role to play in
science and technology investments while
the federal government supports most of
our fundamental research industry
supports a little over half of the
nation's total R&D investment although
many companies have decreased their
in-house basic research many continue to
increase their university research
funding our challenge is to further
stimulate such private investment in
basic research as well as to provide the
fiscal and regulatory conditions to
foster increased applied research and
development it is the only way we might
achieve our goal of higher national
investment in research and development
as percent of our GDP which is the most
direct measure of our national economic
activity from its present level of
investment of about two and a half
percent including defense related
research to perhaps 3 percent of GDP
which is closer to the target of some of
our most competitive
nations in our international trade and
that would mean a an increase of 15
percent from where we began in fiscal
year 93
I think the hopes of achieving that
upward movement in the near term is slim
unless we develop these new kinds of
partnerships and policies that will
foster them in the years ahead well
where have we come in two years
sometimes it seems like ten years but
and sometimes it seems like only a few
months I'll tell you we're halfway
through a four-year term and I can
hardly believe it at this point my wife
can but I but I think we have made a lot
of progress so thanks to the active
participation of virtually everybody in
this room if not everyone in this room
and many more besides of course in terms
of the administration the overriding
issue that we can never get far away
from has to do with the budget and
deficit reduction the president has
delivered on his commitments in this
regard during this period by cutting our
overall federal spending to shrink the
projected annual deficit by about half
over the five years from 1992 to 1998
and approving plans to reduce the size
of federal employment to its lowest
level since the kennedy administration
which is our present a target for 19 in
1997 and we're on target while people
have talked about reducing employment in
the federal government for years and
years and years we've actually done
something about it we have over a
hundred thousand fewer positions now
than we did two years ago it is critical
though that the budget deficit continue
to be brought down because only then can
the capital formation be applied to
things other than than the handling and
increased public debt and therefore
hopefully more capital is able to flow
in to the private sector
it keeps interest rates down it
encourages investment the president's
plan is to further reduce the deficit
mostly through spending cuts as a
percent of our GDP from about 4 percent
which is where we started two years ago
- 2.7 percent of GDP which is on witches
would be the outcome of our proposed 96
budget and on down to about 2.1 percent
of GDP by 1990 by 1997 discretionary
funding will be highly strained under
those conditions even for science until
the deficit spending monster is tamed
and we would now have a balanced budget
I would remind you if it weren't for the
devastating mortgaging of our future
that was undertaken during the 80s the
interest payments on the increase of our
debt during the 80s is now equal to
about 200 billion dollars a year which
is our present deficit annual deficit
and this is a terribly important lesson
I think to all of us on the other hand
if those borrowings that we made had
been applied as true investments in our
future education research infrastructure
that leads to higher productivity rather
than in consumption we might be a lot
better off than today in other words
borrowing itself is not bad it depends
on what you borrow for as a homemaker I
think we all understand this and as
university presidents I think we
understand this but somehow we we need
to recapture the notion of why it is
we're trying to reduce our deficit it's
an it's a means to some ends and we keep
thinking about the means more perhaps
than we're thinking about the ends in
the 96 budget the president targets
about half of the savings to a reduction
in income tax for middle Americans where
the income tax is not across the board
but is targeted toward encouragement of
investments on the part of the
individuals investments in savings in a
first home and an education for their
children the other half goes of the
savings goes to deficit reduction
now while taking these disciplined
fiscal steps the federal investment in
basic research will be maintained as an
priority a fundamental national
investment priority and I would hope
that our recovering economy further will
provide for even more stimulation for
our D in the private sector but in order
to confront the budgetary scientific and
technological challenges of the 21st
century the administration recognized
that significant changes were going to
be needed in the way we plan and carry
out a federal R&D the traditional single
agency single discipline approach to
problem solving must be supplanted by
some better way by a coordinated
multi-agency interdisciplinary approach
as it were a virtual agency within the
federal family so at the end of November
93 the president established the
National Science and Technology Council
which he chairs and members of the
council are the cabinet secretaries and
heads of agencies are concerned with
science and technology and at the same
time he re-established as the
President's Committee of Advisors on
science and technology I would note that
three of the about I think 17 members of
that committee happened to come from MIT
Chuck vest Mario Molina and Phil sharp
and that committee helps provide an
external oversight to the process we're
we're working on processes we're working
on in the Science and Technology Council
the purpose of the council is to
identify national goals that require
concerted rnd investments to identify
the high-priority
research needed to meet those goals and
to coordinate R&D government-wide to
make sure that adequate attention is
given to high-priority areas and to
avoid duplication unnecessary
duplication although each agency to
accomplish its missions must have Rd
directed toward those particular needs
there are many commonalities in the
science and technology
needs of all of the agencies to meet the
nation's goals in the years ahead and to
continue meeting them as the goals
themselves evolve requires that we set
broad priorities for research and
development now with a farsighted vision
of the future because most of the S&T
enterprise is inherently a multi-decade
process it's out of sync with a so
called political time constants of of
change the NSTC provides the mechanism
for providing that vision and deriving
priorities which in turn affect the way
budgets are put together and decisions
are made by creating this virtual
organization we enable the
administration to maintain a productive
research and development activity in
each of the science and technology
dependent agencies while simultaneously
achieving the efficiencies that we must
gain through a cross-linked system I
think it demonstrated some of its
utility
however being only a year old by
assisting in developing a healthy budget
proposal for science and FY 96 there are
some other things that the council has
done but we could talk about those later
the budget request that was released
yesterday with the president reflects
our continued commitment to science even
as we made many extreme exceedingly
difficult priorities decisions during
the last six months or so our efforts to
sustain the investment in fundamental
science were greatly assisted I would
say with pride not only by the active
participation of senior officials of the
executive agencies but also with the
strong support of the President and
vice-president the Office of Management
and Budget and the president cotton
President's Council of Economic Advisors
in summary let me give you just a few
points about the budget first it is a
strong commitment to fundamental science
as a priority national investment second
basic research shows the largest
percentage increase in the budgets for
Science and Technology
third academic research is proposed to
receive an increasing an increase of 7%
more than twice the rate of inflation
while at the same time the discretionary
budget is actually falling so we're
playing a negative sum game overall
slightly negative and yet at the same
time this kind of support of science is
evident and it's being therefore done by
eating other things in the overall
budget a few specific items funding for
NSF research would increase about 8% an
administration initiative to increase
substantially the operation of the deal
II user facilities would have a unique
forefront research tools and serve
thousands of University and industrial
scientists this is to receive a hundred
million dollar appropriation which will
help fund the researchers is a very
large backlog of researchers and and
highly meritorious research available
and it will also help pay for some of
the magnet costs the electric costs
electricity costs of some of these
facilities which have a large embedded
capital investment but are grossly
underutilized some of these facilities
are being presently utilized at only
about the fifty to sixty percent
utilization rate and we feel this is the
extremely high leveraged investment the
budget for NIH would increase 4%
slightly above inflation and NASA and
DOD would maintain their basic science
programs even in the face of very
substantial overall budget reductions
which wasn't an easy thing to do beyond
the very important budgetary initiatives
across the frontiers of basic research
we also have the goals of enhancing our
connections to private to national goals
and to stimulate new partnerships a key
aspect of this and a major focus of this
meeting today is the nurturing of areas
of basic science and engineering which
pretty clearly are needed as found
stations for our 21st century industrial
enterprises we're working hard to
establish better mechanisms for
industrial input to the federal basic
research portfolio indeed Neil Lane and
I met last week with a group of
industrial leaders in research two of
whom I think share the program today
Neil and I greatly profited from that
dialogue as well as another meeting with
Ron Brown and leaders from the
biotechnology industry community there
is a clear consensus among these leaders
that span a broad range of technologies
for instance in the things that came up
most frequently were computers and
communications imaging chemicals
biotechnology and some other areas that
are seen as long-term priority areas of
research in terms of our future
industrial needs and interests we heard
about significant structural change in
all in the various industries that we
talked to for example one company now
has an average age of products in their
business line of about 14 months which
is a reality which clearly shapes
corporate planning in rnd and other
areas and the twin pressure of
foreshortening product life cycles which
which causes one CEO said the company to
lower its headlights in terms of its
long-range planning exacerbated by
increasingly tight margins due to
international competition inherently
draws the focus of industrial planning
to their shorter term futures and that
against gives one a notion that we're
about to re-enter this time of problems
in which industrial interests become
short-term and public interest moves
back closer to the bench in fundamental
science and what's been called a valley
of death opens up again between and
which good ideas fall through and end up
popping up somewhere else in the world
and someone else's economy
we've heard about the desirability for
broadening graduate education of getting
more technical talent in the upper
management we heard about the pressing
needs to resolve intellectual property
issues in the global economy and about
specific areas of basic research which
hold greatest promise for example a
computer assisted molecular modelling
and drug design hold and store very
large product productivity gain
opportunities but most of all we heard a
clear signal through the discussions
that this group viewed federal
government's most important
responsibilities in science and
technology to be sustained and prefer
preferably improved funding of
broad-based fundamental research and its
associated graduate training the
foundation of these companies rests in
basic research as does their long term
strength the private sector has the
admirable trait of a clear focus on
priorities in the long term high margins
require breakthrough technologies which
in turn are often rooted in discipline
based frontier research our industrial
colleagues are also launching new
partnerships with academia as well as
with government we heard about the
successful venture in which competing
companies have joined together in
support of and participation in a joint
on-campus basic research program with
students working in both the campus and
the industrial laboratories as suited to
the work it's clear that dynamic new
partnership models will emerge from the
resourcefulness of industrial and
academic scientists with the resources
of government available to leverage
suitable partnerships and we look to you
for leadership and advice in this area
and I hope we'll hear about some of it
today as a next step we agreed last week
to have a group of industrial research
leaders similar to the group we met with
last week talked to the multi-agency
Committee on fundamental science of the
NSTC which is co-chaired by Neil Lane
Harold
and Marcy Greenwood who's here with me
today Marcy is associate director of
OSTP for science this kind of dialogue
we believe will help shape the federal
portfolio even more across the
participating agencies and I would
remind you as as my wife does for me in
times of frustration that by the time
she cleans up the dishes from one dinner
there's another one on the way that our
FY 97 budget cycle basically begins in
the immediate future it's enough to make
a grown person cry as part of the
administration's response to these
changing times reviews of the
appropriate role and scale of the
nation's National Laboratories
especially of the Department of Energy
NASA and defense was initiated last
spring and in parallel EPA is undergoing
a similar detailed examination of its
laboratories the first of these studies
was delivered just a week ago when Bob
Galvin's committee reported its finding
on the do e National Laboratories to the
department their recommendations for the
future of the Department of Energy
laboratories I think is a valuable
contribution to help set the nation's
scientific agenda and I think there were
four MIT professors on that committee so
it's bound to be pretty good right while
a report has much to say about
governance and oversight of these labs
it's noteworthy that the important the
national importance of both the basic
research done at the labs and the large
user facilities that they operate were
stressed that is not stressed in terms
of physical things but we're stressed in
terms of being emphasized in the report
and it further emphasized that the
department needs to better integrate its
research activities into those of the
national and international communities
and to focus their research activities
in areas at the heart of dealies
missions such as energy and
environmental protection and
environmental remediation
all of these studies are a part in a
sense of reinventing ourselves of
reinventing the way we go about doing
our business in government not only how
to generate internal sources of funds
which is what you have to do when you
play a zero-sum game
but also how to refocus our lives and
the way we approach our businesses we've
given particular emphasis in the first
two years of this administration to a
human resources development strategy
that's aimed at producing the Kadri of
experts that are necessary for the
future for research and development for
applied fields and industries and for
competing in the global marketplace as
universities and industries are
reevaluating the breadth and the nature
of graduate training recognizing that
we're not training our scientists merely
to work in labs and universities but for
a variety of of future kinds of
occupations federal agencies are
assessing how they might provide
supportive incentives to this kind of
rethinking we're also projecting the
workforce needs of our future economy
and developing methods for fostering the
basic skills required for all workers
skills and quantification and
particularly skills that are broad and
enable people to be the kind of
versatile workers that they're going to
end lifelong learners that will be
absolutely requisite as an economic
citizen in the next century and in fact
we're developing plans now for a
national forum on science education that
we hope you'll be interested in helping
us with well now finally if you look a
little bit of a look ahead I think one
of the most exciting and far-ranging
initiatives now underway is the second
phase of the national performance review
or reinventing government which will
have a significant effect on science and
technology reforming and streamlining
federal regulation and identifying more
effective ways to accomplish national
goals would certainly cut the costs of
compliance
undoubtedly it would help free up
resources for more investment in
research and stimulating industrial
technological innovation we hope to move
away from command and control and toward
performance-based kinds of standards
which enable them those who are being
regulated to use their ingenuity and
optimize their systems and arrive at
ends with minimum costs it's even given
rise to terms such as Industrial ecology
which is an interesting new kind of
engineering challenge similarly federal
agencies will move beyond simply making
existing programs work better and more
efficiently to assessing whether the
federal government needs to provide
existing services and pruning programs
that ought to be eliminated
such cost-cutting will result in freeing
up federal resources for further
investments toward the future and that's
our common litany to the agencies we
want you to do new things and you're
going to have to find the money from
within your budget as an example of our
rethinking of federal activities is our
effort to create a simpler streamlined
and more efficient cost reimbursement
system for overheads associated with
research and education grants to
nonprofit institutions while maintaining
adequate incentives for investment in
our world-leading Science Enterprise
this week in the federal register we
proposed a series of revisions which
would discard past notions of quote
direct and indirect costs which were
needlessly complicated and poorly
understood instead three categories of
research costs all necessary for the
conduct of fundamental research are
proffered they are research activities
research facilities research
administration there are many other
changes included in these proposed
revisions which were developed over the
past year by an interagency federal
group working closely with the
university community and we hope that
you will respond to those
that Federal Register notice we'd love
to have your comments we'd like to move
ahead as quickly as we can on this
building on the changes made to the
system by the previous administration
the so-called revised a21 our revisions
would reinvent the system of cost
reimbursement in the spirit of the
national performance review they would
achieve greater uniformity and cost
efficiencies while retaining the core
principles of negotiated cost
reimbursement based on the government
university sharing of actual costs then
assess the necessary stability would be
retained to stimulate universities and
their governing boards to invest in
world-class research and education
facilities we're particularly concerned
over some discussion in the Congress
that as an alternative to these kinds of
revisions in research costs
there could be an overall cap or an
across-the-board cut imposed on
university reimbursement rates we are
opposed to such actions since they would
affect faculty a facility investment
faculty - I guess when a cap on
reimbursement for facility for research
facility costs would be in opposition to
the principles enunciated in science in
the national interest and its policy
statement in which we said we will work
in partnership with universities and the
private sector to modernize our research
infrastructure additionally such a
research facility cap would force
unrealistic uniformity across
institutions that have a diversity of
facilities and costs associated with
them the diversity of our American
research universities has been one of
its great strengths that have led the
u.s. leadership in science math and
engineering lessening our research
pluralism is certainly not in our best
interests and I'm sure you'll probably
want to express your interest on these
issues to your colleagues in Congress
perhaps the most significant challenge
we face now is evident in the
projections of the federal budget beyond
fiscal 96 that was proposed yesterday
American leadership in
and Technology I believe is in grave
danger as we close out this century the
old considered budget cuts could do
great harm to research projects that are
critical investments for our nation's
work in defense economic health and
environmental security if we decide as a
nation to reduce the annual deficit in
more draconian ways than we are trying
and especially if we target only the
domestic discretionary portion of the
budget which accounts for less than 20%
of the total federal budget but contains
most of our science and technology we
run a very great risk that our
investments in the future of our people
our research and institutions will
ratchet down to unacceptably low levels
deficit reduction alone cannot leech us
of all our ills it is not an end in
itself but a means to ends that we must
keep in mind we must continue to make
investments in areas such as research in
education that in turn will enable us
and those who follow to achieve our
aspirations we've we've begun our
dialogue with the new Congress and it's
new leadership the the new Congress I
believe is generally very supportive of
the principles of support of basic
research but there are clearly
significant areas to be resolved
especially in the area of Technology
collaboration with industry we must work
together to advance science and
technology in light of present fiscal
realities we need to ensure that all
Americans are taking part in that in
this economic recovery that we're
undergoing and that the entire public
will be able to benefit from the fruits
of advances in knowledge that's why the
administration does support a tax cut
that is targeted to benefit education
and training investments because the
administration does care deeply about
preparing the American people to
adequately and and substantially to face
the kinds of demands and capture the
opportunities that lie in tomorrow's
economy while few people think of it
that way
science and technology are fundamental
tools for putting people first both
today and tomorrow Oliver Wendell Holmes
said it well when he said true science
knows no bounds it penetrates into every
domain without fear and serves all men
without prejudice or favor it's work is
to substitute facts for appearances
demonstrations for impressions and
beneficial realities for those many
things that ignorance and greed
proclaimed to be impossible for
suffering humanity it is hope and
promise it is also critically important
that we do a better job of communicating
with our benefactors namely the
taxpayers Einstein noted that when he
said it is of great importance that the
general public be given the opportunity
to experience consciously and
intelligently the efforts and results of
scientific research it is not sufficient
that each result be taken up elaborated
and applied to a few specialists in a
field restricting the body of knowledge
to a small group dedenne's the
philosophical spirit of a people and
leads to spiritual poverty I might add
that keeping the spirit of discovery to
ourselves could also lend to another
kind of poverty for science itself so
our budget proposal 496 demonstrates we
believe that the administration has a
strong commitment to science and
technology based on the choices we've
made but we will need to listen
carefully and understand and engage the
people in defining our choices for the
future and I certainly look forward to
that dialogue with you today thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much we will now have two
presentations one from the perspective
of Industry and one from an academic
perspective the first of these will be
by dr. Joseph a Miller currently senior
vice president for research and
development at one of America's leading
companies the DuPont company DuPont is a
company which is simultaneously a
chemical company and an oil company with
sales of the order of thirty billion
dollars annually dr. Miller is the chief
technical officer of this organization
he started at the DuPont company and has
spent his entire career there since
receiving the PhD degree in chemistry
from Pennsylvania State University dr.
Miller has had wide experiences in the
company ranging from research and
development of course to manufacturing
to the business and marketing dr. Miller
has been a very distinguished
contributor in the organization of
course he's a member of the American
Chemical Society the Industrial Research
Institute and the governing board for
the Council for chemical research he is
a member of the board of directors of
the DuPont merck pharmaceutical company
the board of the chemical Heritage
Foundation and the board of the Council
for competitiveness dr. Miller is of
course a chemist chemistry industry is a
large and important one in the United
States and arguably an industry which
has profited significantly from US
investment in research and development
dr. Miller thank you Martin for that
generous introduction he might pass on
to my boss at Woolard I know he's
determining what my bonus and salary
increased you'd be for next year you
also noticed that I'm from Penn State
and I know some people here are Ted
Bednarski here he went to school with me
and we have declared in the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania and in the state of
Delaware that they in fact are national
champions in football and perhaps we can
start a movement in Cambridge here today
to get the same kind
resolution adopted in Massachusetts my
comments this morning are based on
science
having made critical contribution to the
foundation and health of many of our
most economically important industries
information technology materials
pharmaceuticals just to name a few
science in the national interest
provides a structure for continuing the
development of science and high-risk
technology and their associated benefits
industry's perspective on the
recommendations in this document is not
monolithic individual industries have
different needs and there can be
substantial variations between large and
small companies within an industry for
example the Rd Tax Credit will be of
greater benefit to the smaller fast and
grow faster growing companies than the
larger more mature firms but given the
risky environment of the more
entrepreneurial companies it is
important to assist their technical
development we an industry welcome
increasing interaction with universities
in our national labs be they by cratis
exchange of scientific personnel or
research grants for joint programs we
are moving to collaboration rather than
competition in industries interaction
with nonprofit laboratories all to the
good so with that introduction
rather than examine the many facets of
Industry let me focus on that component
I know best the chemical industry and
talk a bit about what's going on at
DuPont chemical industry is a national
treasure our industry has been a
foundation of the United States and the
world economy for most of this century
the strength of its competitive position
is demonstrated by the fact that we've
had a positive balance of payments
for many many decades it's an industry
characterized by steady innovation and
steady growth collaborative spirit that
exists in this industry perhaps unlike
any other between disciplines chemistry
biology engineering mathematics between
industry academia and government it's an
industry that's been involved and very
supportive of basic research and
excellence in education in its industry
that based on strength and our
scientific and technological platforms
has found ways to renew itself and keep
itself strong in the highly competitive
global marketplace and it's an industry
that today faces some very large
challenges environmental challenges even
more aggressive international
competition and the whole issue of
growth and in response it's an industry
that's gone through a great deal of
change massive restructuring
organizational streamlining
globalization we're about a 40 billion
dollar company 50% of what we sell today
is outside the United States about 15%
of our research now is conducted outside
the United States a critical analysis of
research taking place in the chemical
industry pressure for greater
selectivity on what we work research
groups are being brought in closer
contact with the businesses and under
control of the businesses a question
even for the need for corporate research
pressure on corporate research to
develop a greater sense of relevance in
their activities as it relates to the
company companies and the companies
businesses
and do pot hasn't been immune from any
of this we've gone through it all and
the in the bottom line for us is we had
to change in order to survive we're
almost 200 years old the DuPont company
is and throughout our history we have
found ways to renew ourselves and we
intend to survive for another 200 years
so the question of renewal ah faces us
but the changes that have taken place in
our industry and in and in our company
and I know in many of your industries
are irreversible where do we stand today
at DuPont still very tight control on
budgets all kinds of budgets of course
and especially the research budget
emphasis on getting much more for less
and as a result we haven't compromised
we've compromised certain areas but we
haven't compromised areas which we view
as enabling technologies that is that as
technologies that allow our researchers
to be more productive and a little
analytical capability information
science computation and modeling however
we've become a much more structure we've
entered introduced much more structure
around project selection especially in
the latter stages of development or
expense builds very quickly we're an
industry in a company that our character
that are characterized by high capital
intensity intensity so today we have a
greater concentration on process
research our processes have become very
much more complex as our customers had
demanded more and more different kinds
of products for more complex because of
environmental considerations and the
need to be more competitive around cost
and quality
heavy emphasis on new process chemistry
advanced process control a real question
around how we renew our engineering
force who is becoming much more aging
and technology is changing much more
rapidly and we're looking for less brute
force less capital intensive solutions
to our problems we face a need for
growth serious question as to whether we
can grow again like we have in the past
our marketing people need to become much
more technically sophisticated in
interpreting the marketplace and guiding
our research efforts we need many more
ideas to pursue we're running out of
them and I should have brought with me a
quote from Charles Stein but he wrote a
very famous letter in 1926 to our
Executive Committee when he indicated
that we needed to begin a fundamental
research effort because our businesses
were running out of ideas to pursue and
that request led to the hiring of
Wallace Carothers who basically
developed helped start the basic
research that led to development of our
polymer based businesses we're talking
about greater control on development
costs and looking for ways of
compressing the cycle time from
invention to commercialization have a
short that I'd like to show very quick
one as to what we're talking about here
this is how we view the technical
support this is how we view this chain
from science to the marketplace and it's
important that we view it this way
information flowing from science to
what's taking place in the marketplace
and ensure all the connections are in
place so that information flows smoothly
through that through that market chain
and we respond quickly to today's needs
and best understand
tomorrow's needs so that when we we know
when we've made a discovery in our
laboratories so we're looking for ways
of compressing that cycle time love if
you could just and finally at DuPont
corporate research will survive our
mission will change a bit it will be not
only a scientific mission but a
technological mission and there will be
greater relevance on the science side
more connectedness to our competencies
that grew to the competencies that gird
our company we will have the
responsibility for creating the
breakthroughs that will change the
competitive position of our company and
our businesses and we're recognizing
that we can't get it all done ourselves
and that there we must be more dependent
on cooperative programs with academia
and government so with that background
let me take a few moments to address the
content some of the content in science
in the national interest you know in a
few areas basic research education and
scientific literacy we find little to
argue with in this report and are
astounded that some have our quality of
life our economic well-being our place
in this world have been made possible by
the inventiveness and innovative spirit
of the US scientific and industrial
manufacturing institutions and a move to
dismantle such or to impair its
effectiveness will have unfortunate
circumstances long-term a basic research
the knowledge that has come from the
great universities in this city and from
around the United States from the
National Labs or from the great
industrial labs has established the
scientific base for technology
development unequaled by any nation
this work and its support must continue
unabated and I mean support from all
entities that have the capability to and
interest in supporting it in doing so we
must be very careful that the criteria
for such support be not too prescriptive
the desire for government and industrial
leaders to have the scientific community
carefully defined expectations is
contrary to the atmosphere and structure
required for true scientific exploration
with all of its unexpected results and
benefits the process of support for
basic research should not be the sole
responsibility of government if we
expect our key in emerging industries to
excel to win globally to grow in to
prosper we an industry must be involved
including increased funding small as it
may be involved not in the management of
programs not in prescribing their fine
detail not in contract research that
abrogates our responsibilities we must
define broadly those areas where we need
ideas fresh thoughts and where
scientific advances have the potential
to supersede the technologies that exist
today at DuPont when Wallace Carothers
began his work in 1926 the first polymer
commercialized was neoprene the second
was nylon they still exist today
the first nylon plan is in Seaford
Delaware it's 54 years old those
businesses bear no resemblance to what
they did 50 some years ago but in those
businesses in our key businesses we
continue to
dig deeper and deeper and deeper into
the science and with that digging come
the came the ideas to keep those
businesses fresh and renewed and that's
what I'm talking about when I'm talking
about basic research in the interests of
our country or in the interest of our
companies a couple of comments on
education I recognized that education at
the graduate and postdoctoral level is a
sensitive topic and I don't wish to
intrude on university independence here
still for scientists who come to
industry universities have them as a
graduate student for four to six years
probably in Mark's group seven or eight
years we hope to have PhDs for 40 years
so some level of involvement seems
appropriate especially in describing how
the industrial scene has changed in how
we expect it to look to recent
commentaries are worth considering in
this regard the Heindel report from the
ACS which speaks to the need for broadly
trained and more adaptable PhDs the
marry good Neil Lane article in science
this past fall which expands on comments
in national and science in the national
interest and speaks to the importance of
education of professional scientists
both undergraduate and graduate this is
not a case of either/or it's a case of
balance we will always need PhDs in
industry we will need them dispersed
throughout our workforce we will need
them to conduct quality science and
remain in that activity all their
careers we also will need people with an
understanding of what science is all
about
Hiep people who can permanently solve
problems that our businesses face people
who can move around the world people who
are mobile people who are able to
network to work on team
and people who ultimately can move into
key leadership roles reinforced by such
a background we need scientific
scientifically literate managers and
leaders lastly a few words about science
and mathematical literacy and the
preparation taking place in K through 12
I would hope the reasons are clear on
the need for some increased literacy in
science and math they are beautifully
and clearly made in the document that
we're talking about the need for a
healthy supply chain of scientists
mathematicians and engineers the
development of a competent and capable
workforce and the ability to for society
to deal with a myriad of technical
issues that we have to deal with
thankfully there is much going on here
at the national level Triple A s in the
National Research Council and at the
state level and I know here in
Massachusetts and across many and in
many states across the United States
there are efforts we've had a three-year
effort in my state Delaware where I
co-chair the effort to develop science
curriculum content standards for grades
K through 12 however there's a great
deal that stands in the way of such
reform efforts and all of you must get
involved most especially the business
people there are small but very vocal
groups whose interests are in opposition
legislators are under pressure from such
groups and are hesitant and while many
of the education community supports the
effort some don't and they are able to
stymie our efforts and such reform will
require a change in priorities
and a substantial increase in resources
we as a community must make the case for
reform a sense of urgency is required
here together we must articulate how the
world has changed and what is needed to
compete globally we must get parents
legislators the media and the teaching
community involved in such dialogue high
expectations must be set in hell - and
incentives established for performing
against rigorous standards clear
requirements for workforce and College
emission most especially to our state
schools should be set in a way that
there is a clear connection to these
rigorous state standards there is a much
there is much that has to happen here
beyond the development of content
standards so-called content standards
the building of capacity in many areas
will be necessary for successful
implementation of standards curriculum
will need to be developed scope and
sequence in these in this curriculum and
integration between science and math
professional development is a major
issue and resources will need to be
expanded this effort is complex it's
highly emotional it's a new experience
and it will not be successful without
your participation and ownership so the
last couple of years have been an
interesting time for many of us a time
when there have been massive changes
taking place in the research community
while such change is never easy the
benefits are really becoming apparent
industry is partnering to an increasing
degree with universities and with
government laboratories and we in the
nation should all benefit
as a result thank you very much for your
attention I'm astonished at the
remarkable record of public service that
he has given to the community during
that period he has of course led a major
university and simultaneously served in
a number of capacities that have brought
benefits to the university community but
more important to the nation he is by
education a geologist and therefore it
is appropriate that he make a
presentation in a setting such as this
but he has also been a major contributor
to assessments of some of the issues
that we're talking about in connection
with thinking through our future in
terms of the development of human
resources President Rhodes was the chair
of the 1987 National Commission on
minority participation in education in
American life the report that was
produced was entitled one third of a
nation the honorary co-chairs of that
study were presidents Gerald Ford and
Jimmy Carter a bit later President
Rhodes together with Don Peterson former
chairman of the Ford Motor Company was
the co-chair of the 1988 business higher
education forum taskforce on human
capital that produced the report
American potential the human dimension
President Rhodes has been widely
recognized for his accomplishments as a
university leader and public servant he
is also a holder of the Bigsby medal of
the Geological Society and has a number
of honorary degrees from a number of
important institutions President Rhodes
of Cornell University thank you for
joining us
[Applause]
mr. chairman dr. Gibbons dr. Miller
ladies and gentlemen I'm happy to share
this symposium and especially to share
it in this setting in this great
institution which for so many years was
the home to then of our Bush and which
in this particular case offers us a
gathering in a building dedicated to
Jerry Wiesner I can think of no better
place to discuss the role of science in
the national interest I should say that
I'm also glad to speak about the
university's perspective on these issues
in partnership with those from
government in the person of Jack Gibbons
and from industry and the person of dr.
Miller it's not always clear that
industry and and the academic world
approach these questions in exactly the
same way Rowland Schmidt who had
experience in both sectors once said
that the big difference between industry
and the academic world is that an
industrial plant is designed by geniuses
to be run by idiots and a university is
just the reverse I also remember Paul
Gray's distinguished predecessor day of
sex and talking once about the role of a
university president which he defined as
a person who spends half his time
speaking and half his time not listening
and it seems to me we may have much in
common with both government and industry
in that sense I was asked to talk about
our partnerships with industry and the
federal government and especially the
way in which they're reflected in this
report let me just say that if you go
back ten years I think the university's
partnership with industry was under
strain and our partnership with the
federal government was healthy and
strong if you look at those two
partnerships today I think the roles are
different
I think our partnership with industry
has been strengthened and most of the
concerns we had a decade ago have been
resolved proprietary interests the
nature of power
ships and so on on the other hand I
think our partnership with the federal
government is under strain it's not in
crisis it's still strong but I think
it's under strain and I want to explore
those questions we've all paid homage
today to van Busche and it's right that
we should because the document that he
produced 50 years ago at the instruction
of President Roosevelt handed to
President Truman has had a decisive
impact upon everything that has happened
not just in science and technology but
in the general health and well-being of
our nation and the impact of that is to
be measured not simply in league tables
of distinction amongst universities or
in the number of Nobel Prizes but it's
to be measured in better healthcare in
scientific discoveries and a strong
national defense and in new industries
such as biotechnology which scarcely
existed 15 years ago all that as Jack
Gibbons has pointed out both today and
in his testimony a month ago before
Congress speaks to the enormous rate of
return social benefit of federal
investment in science given that legacy
and given that strength it seems to me
that it's worth asking what phase two of
this important document science in the
national interest should look like and
there are two particular questions that
occur to me as a sympathetic reader and
I ought to say upfront that I
congratulate jack on the document I
think it's a powerful one there may be
details in which we differ in emphasis
but overall it's a splendid document two
questions however first at whom is the
document addressed
Vannevar Bush's document was addressed
to the president and the president
followed through this document is signed
by the president and the vice president
at whom is it addressed question number
one and question number two what do we
now do about phase two what do we now do
about implementation I want to talk for
a moment about each of those two
questions the first question is whom who
are the recipients of the document at
whom is it addressed not I hope
only to the scientific community because
that would be preaching to the choir I
take it that there is general support
for the viewpoints represented in this
document is it addressed to the public
well I hope that it is because we
together with the government need to
support just the priorities that are
listed in that document is it addressed
to the government itself to others in
the federal government well I hope so
because if it is then it represents a
real statement of policy framework from
the administration it was disapointing
of course to see no reference to it in
the president's lengthy State of the
Union speech some time ago but clearly
it remains a national priority if it's
something that really represents the
federal policy the five goals that dr.
Gibbons and others have identified here
seem to me to be marvelous and so I
praise him and congratulate him on the
substance of this report the real
question it seems to me is how do we
collectively follow through on phase two
how do we take what is a framework for
policy and develop a detailed statement
from it it is a pre policy statement if
you like it's the skeleton around which
the body of a policy is to be produced
but we need more than a rationale we
need now a blueprint to move this
forward it doesn't provide perhaps
deliberately a statement of priorities
it does not provide a detail plan or a
detailed budget or a detailed time
schedule the closest it comes is to
speak of 3% of gross domestic product as
I quote a reasonable long-term goal for
total R&D investment it may be argued
and I'm sure it is that it was not
intended to have these things in the
report but we need them nonetheless from
where do they come well we were told
that a National Science and Technology
Council in STC and Jack has referred to
it today is the federal body the cabinet
level body devoting itself to those
objectives it came into existence in
November a year ago and it provides a
virtual agency for court
across federal agencies for the
identification of priorities for putting
national goals ahead of parochial needs
of individual agencies it represents
however a government Council dealing
with government council matters
decisions about programs of government
reached by government after discussions
within government and it seems to me one
question that's an important one is how
can we as a community cooperate with
NSTC in developing the more detailed
agenda how often has NSTC met I'm told
that it has met only once I find that
inconceivable but it would be helpful to
know does it have staff is it open to
advice from the scientific community we
have in the budget as as dr. Gibbons has
pointed out a somewhat amplified
statement but if you've read the budget
as I had the opportunity to do late last
night there is again very little detail
how can we help develop what is clearly
an admirable statement of the place of
Science in the national interest how can
we provide input to this important
council on which so much depends well
what do the universities look for in
thinking about the partnership I want to
suggest to you that there are four
particular interests that the
universities have in the current
situation one a clear articulation of
the missions of the various federal
agencies involved in R&D to determine
whether in the context of this document
and others they still make sense
you remember Yogi Berra you've got to be
very careful if you don't know where
you're going because you might
conceivably get there and that's the
problem with the federal agencies let me
give a couple of examples if you look at
the figures for the various federal
agencies in the roundest terms the NSF
budget in total is just over three
billion the NIH budget just over 11
billion the do-e multi program labs
their research base something
approaching 7 billion now what is the
role
of those labs in the post-cold war world
we had a week ago the Galvan report
which was mentioned by dr. Gibbons
I would describe its conclusions a
little less generously than he did I
thought it was a staggeringly harsh
indictment of management practices in
ont and I quote from it a statement that
said it concludes that the existing
budget of do-e exceeds that required to
perform its agenda and yet we found that
in the present budget although that
presumably didn't have the benefit of of
the Galvan report there is an increase
of 488 million dollars for do-e how do
we reconcile that as we talk beyond this
room in terms of federal priorities a
second question how is NASA to perform
its role in the change conditions
NASA's total budget is about nine point
five billion dollars and that's a
substantial amount of the total 90
billion or so of federal R&D how
together can we make sense out of the
role of that particular agency and the
third question just take three amongst
many more what is the administration's
position on defense conversion
universities I think are rightly
criticized in the present climate for
not having a clear sense of mission the
same kind of lack of precision exists
still within federal agencies and one
hopes that NSTC
in collaboration with the scientific
community can begin to address this
question need number one a clear precise
statement of the missions of the several
federal agencies dealing with R&T if you
look at HPCC for example in yesterday's
budget there are no fewer than nine
federal agencies funded to pursue R&D in
their particular area that needs the
sort of synthesis that NSTC promises to
provide the second interest that
universities have as a stable and
sensible funding policy I'm not talking
here about a budget I'm talking about a
policy of funding which
deligh as the research we do and if I
mentioned the the words indirect costs
your eyes will glaze over with a sense
of weariness that mine also experienced
but in fact this is a real issue and I
want to thank Marcy Greenwood who is
here for the leadership she's given in
drawing the universities into
consultation in this particular area I
haven't yet seen the new proposals but
if I say if I if if they contain what I
think they contain then I think this is
the kind of proposal we can live with I
want to say however that we have to
recognize the real costs of doing
research and increasingly if the federal
government does not support these they
will be transferred to student tuition
and that to me is an unacceptable
solution to the problem I know that
students benefit undergraduates and
graduates within the context of a
research university but we cannot
transfer to the backs of students that
which is the proper obligation of the
federal government and we're in great
danger here
especially if caps are instituted and I
was glad to hear Jack Gibbons round
condemnation of them in great danger of
killing the independent private
universities which have been the pace
setters in so much of the research and
development that has taken place the
full costs of conducting research need
to be addressed need number three a
reason statement of program and budgets
for all the federal agencies including
the linkages between research and
education that science and the national
interest stresses so effectively and so
wisely give you a couple of examples
how many graduate students should we
really be supporting to meet our needs
how many scientists in a period where in
some disciplines the success rate for
funding proposals submitted by mature
scientists as they're called is around
25 percent or less how many scientists
should we be supporting and where is
that discussion taking place a science
and the national interest promised on
page 27 to produce a policy on human
resources development is that something
in which
the federal government is still going to
play a leading role or is it something
in which the university is an industry
together should take the initiative and
then question number four as far as the
interest of universities go what is the
appropriate level of federal oversight
for operations it supports within the
universities given the need to balance
the benefits of that oversight against
the costs may give you a couple of
examples MIT Cornell and 50 something
other institutions were accused by the
Justice Department some years ago of
price fixing in tuition and financial
aid it costs our institutions something
like twenty million dollars collectively
to defend ourselves in that suit and one
example of the unequal contest and we
obtained a consent decree settlement in
the end was one that my friend Paul gray
described some years ago where one
representative of MIT went into a
meeting with the Department of Justice
and found himself confronted by 30
lawyers and economists from the federal
government side of the table it seems to
me that we need federal agencies to
cooperate with one another in analyzing
the question of how much scrutiny is
enough and it's not just from agencies
such as the Department of Justice take
for example the ONR Stanford a debate on
indirect costs and I do nothing now to
defend the misuse of indirect costs
which have been reported but that that
division began when it was alleged that
Stanford had overcharged something like
a hundred and eighty five million
dollars in indirect costs during the 80s
in October of last year this case was
settled and it was settled when Stanford
agreed to pay 1.2 million dollars and
the Navy said that the investigation had
found no evidence of fraud or wrongdoing
on the part of Stanford but over that
two-year period Stanford had to
and 25 million dollars in external fees
in order to justify its position one
could go on even within agencies such as
the National Science Foundation and
others that support research on the
campus offices of inspectors general now
have vast powers of intrusion into
research labs how much oversight is
prudent and productive are we in danger
of crossing the line and killing the
goose that lays the golden egg so those
are the questions that we need to
address I've been encouraged in spending
a couple of days in Washington this last
week and talking to about 16 or 17
people in the New York congressional
delegation as well as congressman George
Brown and Robert Walker in seeing the
bipartisan support there is for science
and in reaching a solution that will
address our needs but universities are
particularly interested in those four
aspects if we can get that right if
together we can cooperate with dr.
Gibbons and his colleagues and the
administration in making a reality out
of this important document
then we shall prevent that document
being the basis simply for regional
debates amongst the converted 50 years
from now those gathering in this
auditorium will say that the document
science in the national interest was the
defining moment of this administration
and was the foundation for our nation's
prosperity and strength we need to work
together to make that a reality
[Applause]
thank you let me invite the three
presenters to take a chair and submit
themselves to some questions are there
questions I really appreciate the
challenges that you laid out making it a
real valuable the question I wanted to
get your perspective on is one of the
setting of priorities because we've
struggled with this very much from the
anesthesia process and we probably look
at their extensions with others and I
want to reflect on your comment of how
much oversight enough because I guess
what I would ask back to you is how much
defining of what's - for us priorities
you think should be done in the federal
level or should it be more the kinds of
priorities that deal with the kind of
process because we develop for example
should we be talking about program
priorities how much money in physical
sciences Biological Sciences Social
Sciences or should we be talking about
how much money in merit reviewed types
of research in which there is already in
structure of external advisory boards
that determines within an agency or even
potentially to develop across agencies a
mechanism for scientific guidance
because I think there is
tremendous danger in trying to delude
ourselves into believing that we know
how much social science how much
physical science and that we could end
up eviscerating the process of advisory
for it's actually consulting the people
what are you looking for hmm Marcy I
think the the way you are going about it
is exactly the right way and it seems to
me what you've done what you and Jack
have done is something that's
refreshingly new and effective what you
have developed is not Justin is not just
agency budgets and priorities but
cross-cutting items within those the
other things that seem to me to need
address are the questions of whether we
are giving the proper emphasis and
support for individual initiated
investigator Awards how well national
centers are performing not just in one
agency but in all agencies the questions
I raised about the the proper role in
graduate student education but I agree
with you I would not be wildly excited
about seeing the federal government
getting down within disciplines and
picking particular winners either in
industry or academia I think that the
broad categorical emphasis you're giving
is exactly the right one that I welcome
there other questions yes sir right here
Stanford in that effort to reply to
government the Galvan Committee also
essentially condemned the do eat from
the bureaucracy point of view by
government right now with a very curious
jack if you could say something about
though what you look how read the very
definition of government might apply to
it
like the dealy wellwe've yard the
question had to do with the fact that we
have things like the Galvan Committee
study if do-e which was initiated by the
secretary but how is that gonna
transform in some practical way in terms
of reinventing government that first of
all the Galvan's report has just been
delivered I haven't read the full report
myself yet I've met with a committee a
couple of times
and read the summary and I think Frank's
characterization is right that but while
that it does have some good things to
say about the islands of excellence and
facilities and other things it is a I
think a welcome Lea candid and critical
review of the way that institution has
is now managed it's as a as a management
structure not only its headquarters but
its field operations and laboratories
and mics and I hope and one reason we
pushed on Bob to finish that work up at
least to have a thing in hand in
February rather than in June was to
begin to take advantage of it in a thing
that the president has asked us to do in
the OSTP namely to take the review and
the results of the Galvan study a do e
of Johnny foster study of NASA's centers
of the work similar base closing and
other not base closing that the review
of the laboratories within the
Department of Defense and to an extent
the work that that EPA has been doing
and examining their laboratories and
seeing what common threads emerge from
these reviews of the federal presence in
federal laboratories and where we ought
to go from here and of course you don't
want to test deepwater with both feet
but I think there are some common things
that that are emerging from these
studies beginning with Bob Galvin things
that are going to give us a much more
thoughtful basis for action in the
months ahead so I think what you will
see is that the Galvin committee's
report will be a a key instrument in a
collection of instruments that the Vice
President will
and of course it working with him on
this in the way these agencies reinvent
themselves now hazel O'Leary secretary
O'Leary is already using this her input
to the budget process is already
beginning to reflect this and it will
most definitely be reflected in the 97
budget thank you here's the microphone I
wanted to follow up on the discussion
about the communication and I think you
talked about it dr. Gibbons in your
address this this issue of communicating
strongly and to the broad public what
benefits we are getting from government
involvement in R&D I just I just believe
this is so poorly done right now we're
just missing so many opportunities I'm
just struck by new people in the
Congress telling us about a wonderful
the internet is and it is but this was
something that the government and artha
and you know people who started a long
time ago
as was biotechnology has been a
completely funded by the government and
everybody agrees is the it is the
industry of the future how come we can't
get this kind of acknowledgment by the
public by the voting public to support
this activity why why don't we advertise
on the Superbowl we have to do we've got
to raise the ante here we're not getting
the message across
Jack why don't you take a crack at that
and Joe why don't you also and see if we
can get something on the Orange Bowl or
Rose Bowl see it's a million dollars
every 30 seconds I think was the Super
Bowl Henry you're absolutely right and I
think it's interesting just yesterday
afternoon I was with the president when
he sat down in front of a workstation
and started playing with the World Wide
Web and visit to the White House and
even sent himself SAN email message and
began to explore the the where to find
his own budget 496 which is already on
the internet and I think we need more of
those personalizations of leaders taking
advantage of this thing and more
multiple encounters with the public
beginning as much as we can
with the media on what is there how it
did derive from a defense based DARPA
work move to NSF now is virtually
self-supporting and is growing at what
fifteen twenty percent a month I guess
still Anita and and it's an Xterra Blee
exciting thing it has the rest of the
countries they're really nervous because
it is such a potent force for our future
capabilities as a nation and we do need
to talk more about that's the reason I
picked that Einstein quote we just don't
think enough often enough to take off
time from our very busy lives and talk
about what we're trying to do and if we
don't then our benefactors aren't gonna
be that much interested in us you know
if Mozart and Beethoven wrote for their
benefactors and if they didn't deliver
they wouldn't have had a chance to to
compose we have the same problem Joan
you will to come in those yeah I just
make a couple comments I think it has to
it can't be with with macro
communications a lot of us need to be
involved in more personal communications
the state of Delaware defined by the
chemical industry the populace of
Delaware eight hundred thousand or so
don't understand basically what the
chemical industry is all about the
connection between between science and
technology I spent a great deal of time
in this scientific literacy work talking
to small groups citizens groups special
interest groups PTA groups about that
and and you can see the lights come on
you can see the understanding develop
but it takes a lot of time in a personal
time by all of us to get that message
across thank you John
Frank had to say and in particular where
he discussed the NSTC as a separate body
very curious Joe business and mine
operate around the world we have
facilities and manufacturing plants in
about 25 countries and I think it's
certainly correct that the greatest
adversarial relationship exists in the
United States the notion that that
regulatory processes are adversarial
that interactions with the government in
general are there's an us and there's a
them the United States
not a single substantive body in which
all three of those represented at the
table sit for serious decision-making or
very serious input you have advisory
bodies that are one to another but not
substantive bodies that in which all
three sit down as serious partners I'll
take first crack joined I have a very
good friend firstly his name's John
Dingell who has not fallen from grace
but has fallen from chair which is even
more important sometimes and I think the
kind of strict oversight that John
presented during his reign as chair of
the Commerce Committee certainly had a
number of Admiral features admirable
features to it but it also introduced a
lot of of tension between groups for
instance between government between
agencies between the executive and the
legislative and and I sense a kind of a
new mood that operates now with this
change in the committee's jurisdictions
and powers quite honestly and I believe
that we have a better opportunity to
talk about productive partnerships
between the various actors of our
the national scene in terms of the and
this means in terms of of the so-called
Federal Advisory Committee Act and other
things that were created by Congress
when they didn't trust the
administration back in the 80s and
created these barriers to in in a sense
barriers to communicate to effective
communication we have used a lot of ad
hoc mechanisms which really don't get
around the Federal Advisory Committee
Act but at least try to deal with it
realistically the meeting we held the
other day that Levine Chaudhary and
others here today were involved in we
didn't have to publish that in the
Federal Register and do all the other
things that the traps that were put in
place during the next decade we have
organized under the NSTC a variety of
forums typically at the academy with the
sponsorship of the academies which
enable us a lot of dialogue without the
necessary trappings of these
arrangements we work with the Council on
competitiveness which of course is of
his a body of both industry and
university and government can be invited
and we're delighted to be there but I
think we do need to work at this because
the president's feeling is that we've
got a lot of self-interest in working
the public-private self-interest role
and when you can find those interests
lined up as we did in the partnership
for a new generation of vehicles then
you have an opportunity to do some
things in which everyone has both money
on the table
self-interest represented and an
opportunity to have the whole greater
than the sum of the parts well we've
gotten we have to get away from some of
the more litigious is that the right
word litigious nature of our society I
don't claim we ought to go as far as
Shakespeare's Richard the third when he
said first we'll kill all the lawyers
but
[Applause]
maybe not a bad start
someone sent them quiet does New Jersey
have all the toxic waste dumps in New
York City has all the lawyers and the
answer was well New Jersey got first
choice but we do it we have a lot of
work to do and with the help John and
frankly of for instance motors in this
auto automobile partnership is a good
example of where we've overcome a lot of
these issues and and I hope we'll have
many worth of similar examples in them
what's ahead as the research positions
and dry up in the traditional government
labs university settings and industrial
laboratories a lot of the highly trained
technical personnel are looking to a
segment of the community called contract
research and development organizations
for potential positions and in fact Bob
white in a column and Technology Review
not too many months ago even closed the
idea that this was the logical use for
surplus VOE National Laboratories to
subsidize them to go into a competition
with the existing contract or India I'd
like to know if you see a place at the
future table for free standing both
for-profit and not-for-profit contract
or
all of all the talks of sporting talk
about the normal Trinity of the
technical world the academic government
industry do you see the place
participant I think both Joey couldn't
respond to them I think only from our
standpoint where and there's a special
task that needs to be reformed some type
of service that needs to be performed
but we're very careful about that this
whole business cycle time is very very
important and and that comes with with
understanding and connections and
networking and and all of that and the
development process very complicated and
integrated and so we look very carefully
we don't do a lot of contract research
only special outside service type of
work and we don't consider the work that
we do at the universities contract
research either it's we just don't enter
into it with that spirit we don't think
it's very productive
other comments or questions yes of
course concerned with developing the
best scientific manpower or the future
all of our speakers have addressed
vampire and yet at the same time now
we're looking at our manpower needs in
graduate education as
in postdocs and praying scientists and
we're seeing constrained resources for
people who are going in this science and
we're also saying the same thing in
medicine how do we address our manpower
needs appropriately I think the biggest
single obstacle not the only one but the
biggest single obstacle to a strong
supply of men and women in in the
scientific and technical stream is the
glaring inadequacy of education at the K
through 12 level and in the universities
I think we do a very poor job in the
Universities of elementary courses in
the Natural Sciences mathematics and
engineering and I think we have work to
do in all those areas there is secondary
work to be done between all of us in
terms of supporting graduate students in
terms of recruiting them to positions of
reasonable responsibility and
compensation but I think the biggest
single obstacle lies in the school
system and in the universities and
colleges where we've simply not faced up
to the inadequacies of what we do I
think in many arenas right now we're
actually looking at the downsize and
you're talking about the coming
we are looking at what are we doing to
downsize well there are two aspects to
that one is the general level of
literacy and competence that certainly
all three of us at the table believe is
a very important component and that
speaks both to school and college but it
seems to me when we look at the more
general question of the needs and this
is something where I hope there will be
discussions between us 50% of the
graduate students in many of our
engineering PhD programs are non-us
citizens now there's a healthy balance
in that but whether that's the right
percentage is another question what
we've really got to do is to ensure that
we have a strong supply of people coming
forward not all of whom will become
professors thank heavens but many of
whom will go into into venture capital
into into public service into leadership
in a host of fields and I think we have
to be candid with them so far as we can
assess what the opportunities are going
to be in conventional scientific and
technology areas but I hope we shall
strengthen that stream because I think
it's not it's not an adequate one at
present even in the context of
downsizing I think that's a very good
question how does one sustain enthusiasm
to pursue the opportunities in an era
when you see the major corporations
which have been technology driven either
downsizing or holding their own
perhaps Joe Miller again could comment
on how they've managed if they have to
sustain aggressive hiring of outstanding
people and maintain morale and an era of
constraint I just we've continued to
hire not as many as we have in the past
we continue to move our PhD scientists
and engineers out of our corporate labs
into the businesses to fill openings and
the businesses the businesses feel very
strongly about having people trained to
think broadly and completely and so it's
it's a very dynamic situation that we
have and that commitment starts with our
chief executive officer because he feels
very strongly about maintaining the
competence of the corporate
also we feel that that the solution to
this has its roots in basic research
creating new opportunities new business
opportunities with which will result in
growth and with growth a greater demand
for technically trained people so we're
not going to solve the problem by
walking away from basic research in fact
I believe it strengthens the case for
basic research